the suspect is in custody this morning
after the shooting of two police
officers at a Dallas home depot 29 year
old armando juarez was arrested last
night after a police chase and manhunt
he faces charges of aggravated assault
against a public servant the officers
and a home depot employee were shot and
critically wounded hours earlier
Omar Villafranca was outside the home
depot in Dallas with what led to this
attack Omar good morning good morning
the suspect Armando wadda has had on
that standing warrant for felony theft
when officers approached him inside this
home depot and after the shooting one of
the many cameras in and around the store
spotted him leaving in a white pickup
truck after frantically searching nearby
neighborhoods and even a creek bed
police caught up with him less than 10
miles away behind the wheel of a white
pickup truck
investigators say Armando wadis sped
through Dallas neighborhoods as he was
chased by an army of police Tuesday
night wait truck and they're currently
shooting at officers
he drove across grass fields and downed
residential sidewalks eventually wadis
crashed on a dead-end street where he
and a female passenger were taken into
custody arrests ended a five-hour
manhunt
following a shooting at a home depot in
Dallas the incident began around 4:00
p.m. when police were called to the
store about a shoplifter chaotic
everybody took off running shortly after
Dallas Police officers arrived whatas
allegedly opened fire it was about seven
shots that we heard
I seen two officers down like surrounded
couldn't puddle of blood Dallas Mayor
Mike Rawlings called the shooting an
attack on the police department I am
continued to be upset and the lack of
respect of our police but why does his
grandmother couldn't believe it my
grandson he don't carry again you don't
have a gun he's not that kind of person
a source told KTVT that one of the
officers was shot in the head another
one was shot in the face the Home Depot
employee who was shot was a loss
prevention officer and police are not
giving us an update on their conditions
but they are telling us that all
three of them are out of surgery Jon
memmer Anna thanks that's good to hear
it reminds us of course in 2016 the five
police officers who were killed nine
were injured in that shooting